c'est de là que j'ai rencontré antoine
alors antoine par hasard des
taxidermistes donc il a fait cinq mois
la spa de melun mais bon tu en résumé
les gentils cultivait attention départ
mené depuis deux heures et puis toi tu
goûtes emmènera au petit sourire mais tu
vois par acte exactement dans leur la
signer aux femmes depuis des siècles ces
cépages foutry billets en en 2021 à akwa
de droits de vote chéquier mitton je
vois non oui bah excuse moi c'est juste
un rencard là tu pomponne fait en valeur
tu passe un bon moment sais tu te mets
en valeur 10 5 a dit d'accord et donc tu
es un objet en fait pour te mettre en
gage alors je suis à grains objets et ta
valeur elle dépend de quoi du nombre de
poils que tu t'es epinay genre tarn
appart en fait tu n as pas là qu'on
visite il a fallu que je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais c'était pas le
plaza avoir rendez-vous il fait du home
staging et les meufs avant rendez-vous à
elle fondu samedi
boom a pas que ce soit le moment de
faire des vannes un nom est ce que je
suis en impro là c'est un premier jet
c'est pour ça que la mystique on sera
peut-être des vannes
après on fait un sketch après tu vois
bon je sais plus ce que je disais qu'est
ce qu'on fait tu pourrais je sais je
vais rire en ayant très froid quoi ça
donne l'air sexy c'est assez général tu
vois c'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
si je peux me permettre je t'invite ça
me fait plaisir vraiment s'il vous plaît
gallant est rapide
j'ai même pas eu le temps de faire
semblant de sortir la carte bleue une
manipulation patriarcale tu vois ce qui
se passe là ils payent inconsciemment tu
te sens redevable et si tu couche pas
avec lui ténin gratuit voir le mécanisme
qui se met en place non mais c'est juste
romantique
on savait que ça veut dire qu'il a envie
qu'on se revoie et bardon ça fait
plaisir à l'ego coincer je te rappelle
que mouvement nous ya deux mois et non
mais ça n'a rien à voir pardon mais moi
je te parle de l'argent en tant qu'objet
de pouvoir ce que la cc c'est pas sa
carte bleue qu'il est en train de sortir
c'est son pénis si sa carte bleue c'est
son pénis j'aimerais ne pas voir la
gamme de son portefeuille
as-tu choisi mehdi pic il faut qu'on se
positionne sur l'addition ça conditionne
le reste de la relation c'est hyper
important
ok je propose ont dit ok pour cette fois
ci et la prochaine fois c'est un qui
paye non non non on s'assume en femme
libre indépendante puissante et on
l'invite ont pas ils auraient sauté
inquiète si c'est un mec bien qui
comprendra à temps non parce que non
vraiment innovante et ça me plaît chez
moi mais c'est vraiment parce que je
passe une très bonne soirée avec toi
mais la prochaine fois je te préviens
c'est pour moi d'accord enfin c'est
ainsi c'est à une prochaine fois
moi j'aimerais et aucun souci et il nous
a traitées en égales c'est un mec bien
on est d'accord mais là ça fait plaisir
de voir que c'est réglé et qu'on se
prend pas la tête
ah bah non non ne soit pas la tête mais
lui par contre il va nous prendre
ok bon je propose qu'on l'appelle de
main et tente un petit bisou dont j'ai
bien envie ou [ __ ] j'en fait mais
pardon mais si tu as envie de passer la
soirée avec les battues je suis battu
propose un dernier dring à la maison ok
ok pour un petit bisou mais je suis pas
si je suis ok pour la suite débutant
mais ça ne s'est pas tu cites a envie de
lui tu lui dis plus basses ta [ __ ] pas
envie de lui bac tu lui dis et s'est
hissé en tête obligé en fait on va juste
le nom même si je sais pas négocier je
veux pas le premier soir je ne suis pas
une fille facile je pas comme ça donc
mon nom ça ça m'étonnerait tu veux pas
concevoir un nom c'est que coule donc je
m'entraîne je comprends il n'y a pas de
souci je te plaît pas c'est pas très
grave
ah non mais avant aucun souci vraiment
je suis pas je vais
bonne soirée à tous à temps oui reste
prêt à temps
non pas à temps resterai stress je
comprends pas je passe tout le reste
en fait c'est simple si j'ai pas envie
de toi j'ai le droit de te le dire tu
vois ce que je peux rentrer chez moi
maintenant j'ai le droit
[Musique]